here with reaction Texas Senator Ted
Cruz is with US senator I want to uh I
want to read to you something this is
the conclusion of the Department of
Justice on the effectiveness of the salt
assault weapons ban
should it be renewed the bans effects on
gun violence are likely to be small at
best
and perhaps too small for Reliable
measurement if we can put that on the
screen when you couple that with Joe
Biden saying that we should repeal the
liability of gun manufacturers but yet
on the other hand he's saying I'm not
trying to take you guns away uh I would
say he's trying to take our guns away
well look what you put on the screen is
the conclusion of the Department of
Justice for 10 years we had in place a
ban on so-called assault weapons and
according to the Department of Justice
it did not have a meaningful effect on
violent crime the Democrats know this
you know I got to say I was listening to
your monologue and and I usually agree
with you Sean there's one thing you said
tonight that I disagree with you you
said that Biden promised to unify
America and he lied I got to say he has
unified America just about everybody
agrees he's doing a terrible job just
about everybody agrees this is a train
wreck and and you know what's
frustrating about it Sean
is he's not willing to change he he's
not willing to change course this speech
tonight
once again he chose to double down on
hard left divisive politics you know
when it comes to violent crime listen I
was at Uvalde last week the day after
the shooting I was there with with the
local officials and with law enforcement
and and with family members what
happened in Texas is horrific and anyone
with with any heartbeat is horrified
that 19 little boys and girls were
murdered that two teachers were murdered
and what is Joe Biden and the Democrats
do they don't come back and say let's
unite Behind law enforcement to stop
criminals to keep our kids safe no they
immediately demagogue and say the
solution is to take away your weapons
the solution is to disarm law-abiding
citizens and I gotta say you replayed a
snippet of Biden's speech to where he
said it is unconscionable that
Republicans won't allow a debate well
you know what Joe Biden in 2013 he was
president of the Senate he was vice
president of the United States when the
Democrats filibustered my legislation
that would have directed the Department
of Justice to prosecute violent
criminals who tried illegally buy guns
that would have directed the Department
of Justice to audit Federal convictions
to make sure the in the background check
system that could have stopped the
horrific shooting in Sutherland Springs
Texas the church shooting because the
Obama Air Force never reported that
Shooter's conviction to the database but
also part of my legislation the Grassley
Crews legislation was 300 million
dollars for school safety which could
have perhaps prevented this horrific
crime in Uvalde and Joe Biden and the
Democrats filibustered that legislation
52 Senators voted for it nine Democrats
voted for it we had bipartisan agreement
and the Democrats cynically said if we
can't disarm law-abiding citizens we the
Democrats are not willing to do anything
to secure are schools just this week Joe
Biden says he doesn't believe in
hardening schools and making them safer
well that is cynical and it's wrong and
unfortunately it it is a set of policy
proposals with the Democrats are putting
forward would not stop these horrible
crimes instead it's their political
objective
why don't we start with this why don't
we refund the police stop dismantling
the police and why don't we keep those
criminals in jail and abandon these no
no bail laws that like even violent
criminals out without paying a penny in
bail so they're back out on the streets
by their very nature criminals don't
obey laws uh and the CDC even points out
Senator 2.5 million times a year
Americans use legal firearms to protect
themselves and their families so that
would seem to me part of an argument
that that they don't want to talk about
look that's exactly right even the Obama
White House admitted that Firearms are
used defensively to stop crimes upwards
of a million times a year even the Obama
White House and and and and these
leftists want to take those Firearms
away so that people are defenseless to
defend their families that they won't
focus on on the criminals they won't
focus on the bad guys and I gotta say it
was really frustrating being down in
Uvaldi seeing what happened because I
was also on the ground at Santa Fe the
Santa Fe High School is is less than an
hour from my house I was there within an
hour or so of when that horrific
shooting happened
and I I remember sitting down at Round
Tables with the families from Santa Fe
and one of the things they talked about
was best practices how do you how do you
make us a school safer and and if you
look at the Santa Fe shooter what he did
is he entered through an unlocked back
door he made it into a classroom when he
was able to start murdering students and
one of the best practices that Security
Experts will tell you is to harden
schools so that you don't have unlocked
back doors you send everyone through one
Central entrance which by the way
Federal courthouses have Federal
buildings have banks have and at that
entrance you have armed police officers
and I've been championing the fight to
provide funding for police officers in
schools and what was so maddening in
Uvalde is this guy also went through an
open back door got into the classroom
and began murdering children if we had
passed that grant funding if that door
had been locked if there'd only been one
entrance and if there had been armed
police officers at that entrance those
police officers could have killed that
monster before he murdered those 19
students Senator I thought
I think either the only other person
besides myself and maybe you were there
before me I don't know Champion what I
believe is the answer offering the same
protection that highly elected officials
on the state level Federal level we pay
for their protection our children
deserve no less Senator Cruz great to
have you thank you for joining us hey
Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else